[Music]
episode opens on all the main characters
eating cliche also eating something that
very much looks like breakfast for lunch
any clue when our house guest is finally
going to leave if you all continue to
talk loud enough for him to hear you
through the open Archway in the adjacent
room this problem may solve itself we
don't have a ceiling fan homes that
don't come with ceiling fans
pre-installed anyway then I got fir from
my job my wife left me uh broke both my
legs failed the bar exam bar exams if
you go to school for 4 years to learn
how to do a job there's no need for an
additional test afterward either
incorporate the exam into law school or
abolish it as it stands now it's just a
way to gatekeep an already profession
but I didn't mean to get so serious so
I'll hand things back to you Mr Poopy
butthole oh we I'm Mr Poopy butthole and
this is Rick and Morty season seven
breaking the fourth wall with your poopy
butthole hey buddy brought you coffee
calling your grandfather buddy he's not
your buddy he's your grandfather friends
aren't family and family aren't friends
the quicker we all understand that the
easier will'll be to tell your boss to
off when he tries to make you feel like
sh by using the expression we're all
family here and no you're fing not I
apologize for raising my voice I might
be working out some things thank you all
for being very understanding cuz I have
to say I really think of you all as
family damn
it okay I need to make gravity part of
its finished business and leave floors
unfinished how would making the floors
unfinished help the ghost to stop from
facing through said floor possible I
don't understand the differences between
finished and unfinished in this context
but I'm also questioning a person that's
so intelligent they can create robot
ghosts so maybe I'm the unfinished
aspect of this scenario damn it Rick and
Morty quit making me contemplate the
psychological and philosophical aspects
of a scene I just want to hear poopy
butth hole said a couple hundred more
times is this an intervention of me not
intervening it appears so and that is
way too much interventioning of the
intervening while while everyone else is
intervening the intervention you're mean
Dad pick your battles honey yeah you
summer so we're not only getting a new
voice for Rick but also a character
trait that appreciates Jerry because I'm
not okay with that second thing I also
found your Federation Hitler don't go
through my stuff bird kids let's SW him
to a bar it would undercut our messaging
bird person would be the licensed
intervention officer at TV
sins not wearing a helmet while you're
riding a motorcycle bird daughter is a
total if you're a parent you can say
that you most certainly cannot well
should we do
shots Let's Get r rgy love the
enthusiasm and bad decision- making but
those aren't chot glasses those are WIS
and glasses if you're going to have a
drinking problem at least be accurate
about it this horrible bartender who
turns his back on four pores that one's
not my belly
button what is it why is everyone
assuming that the non- belly button hole
is the one closest to the human pubic
area this creature's non- belly button
could be anywhere and they should all be
looking alarmed I refuse to believe that
of all the moments in history this man
has zero P leave the tank we're on Earth
Earth has people who can grow wings out
of their backsides have I missed the
episode where humans and aliens are
living together in Rave Harmony Hugh
married my cousin which I guess makes
him a wolverine law hold it right Javier
bub we'll do the dad jokes around here
and we will happily claw our way into a
pun off so you know watch it Amman is
Australian slang forish damn it austr
get all the best slang did you know in
the land down under they call sheep
jumbucks jumbucks we say sheep because
they make that sound but they're all
like that these floofs are jumb bucks no
one will ever need to know why don't
accept other people's limitations that's
horrible advice when I ignored my
friends limitations and tried to hit 125
while driving in rural Oklahoma I lost
control and killed well nothing it's
Oklahoma there's really nothing to hit
but I did Total my 1995 Ford Contour
that was like a $500 mistake and after
words I had to drive my cousin's geom
Metro for 6 months which is a fate worse
than death so maybe accept some
limitations you're a vampire brother you
feed off other people's energy outside
of what we do in the shadows this is not
how vampires work and Hugh Jackman you
are know what we do in the shadows I
know it hurts to hear but I just like to
rip the Band-Aid off immediately A real
friend would have known it's not my
birthday basing friendship on whether or
not someone knows your birthday because
to be clear no one remembers your
birthday unless you're on Facebook and
then don't kid yourself they didn't
remember then either they just pressed a
button to send you fake confetti you
think I don't know a half ass
Intervention when I see one coming
nearly every participant of A's
intervention somehow makes its way into
the episode now now did you do this
go not seeing all these people when you
were looking right at them just a second
ago pb's baby doesn't have shards of
glass stuck in its face also kidnapping
that's not mud but if the animators
can't make the that's not mud look like
something other than the regular mud
then how is it
[Music]
funny oh no matter how niick I can be
the show always makes me laugh good to
know that even when there are major
changes the product doesn't suffer why
is this my thing being this upset that
you have the ability to suck on your own
Gears yes you didn't see season 4
episode 3 assuming most of your audience
stuck around after season 3 who's got
the three dots on their forehead now to
be fair those three dots were there the
whole time these four inebriated
individuals one of which is fing Jean
take down a predator oh we a musk no
that's a flint lock pistol a musk's a
long gun learn how to properly Second
Amendment PB or get the out of this
country Rick it was canonical to see you
you might want to hold off on to
clearing Canon until the new voice
actors settle into their roles captain
in touch with the guys over the years as
much as you can in this fast world poopy
but whole narration poy rtion Nar a
butthole Gearhead went back to the Gear
system and got a spinal replacement he's
still paying it off America's Healthcare
System and possibly to put a bullet in
all future Wolverine references with
Deadpool 3 on the way doubt it I could
3D print you an apartment on the moon
waiting until this very moment to offer
that solution sounds like you should
have started with that well here I go
pilling again we didn't see anyone pop a
fading pill before so the effects must
have taken longer than they do now which
only means the fade pill works fully in
time with the plot discount animated Sam
Elliott so he could have survived if he
just stood back 5T well to be fair when
he was being mowed over it slowed the
vehicle down significantly grinding up a
body takes a lot of effort for a lawn
mower don't ask me how I know
that I'm just going to let it dangle
Jerry pay the dealer pay that me his
money hey buddy brought you coffee it's
k k k coming to K Kil me dad you can't
keep putting this off you're doing an
intervention with us NOP intervention
intervention is nothing private Frank
you know this can't make the concept
work not comedically or clinically it
success rate is 10% in both areas it was
my understanding that there would be no
math I hired a predator to follow her
around that's not a predator that's a
sports Hunter if you strike me down I
shall become more powerful than you can
possibly imagine